[Music]  the gnome redid our experience it in  IMAX September 7th  here to investigate the death of a nun  September 7 witnessed the darkest  chapter 35 in the country universe  [Applause]  from rated-r I had a series of visions  when I was younger but after each want  the same father would be stuck in my  head  I saw none experienced it in IMAX  September 7 fretted our  I had a series of visions when I was  younger and after each one ended the  same thought would be stuck in my head  parts Jessie I saw none  or do my visions reach the church and I  was asked to accompany a priest to an  abbey in Romania the Abbey has a long  history what she may hate down  Callahan's here  [Music]  [Music]  you  you